he is our NFL Network insider he has a
podcast now rap sheet and friends he is
not appearing today with his friends
only himself Ian Rapoport how are you
I'm good how are you I'm good I'm doing
this which is fun I assume you're busy
waiting for trades to happen although
although even though the Carlos Hyde
trade happened on a Friday would you be
surprised if a trade went down today
before the full schedule Sunday yeah I
mean even not you know even naturally
the timing sort of didn't make much
sense because they trade it for him I
mean I guess what you do is you prevent
a guy from playing in the next game so
he doesn't get injured but the timing
doesn't actually make sense because you
know they trade it for him that he's in
play so why bother yeah why bother is
there a big name that you think could be
traded that would stun people or
surprise people by Tuesday you know I
don't I don't think it'll be anything
that was really surprised but at this
point because so much gets out in the
public you know I mean if someone needed
a quarterback you know someone needed a
quarterback than maybe Sam Bradford
could be traded I think that was you
know probably that surprised people but
if there was a quarterback injury and
Bradford was sort of the recipe then
we've been there before without open
some eyes other than that I mean you
know most of the guys at this point who
are going to be traded you know it's not
going to be someone like Josh Gordon a
young guy with a low salary it's gonna
be an old guy with a high salary the
miners Thomas could be traded that would
be one you know depending on how the
Broncos do I think that would be big
news Pro Bowler i opening you know how
much actual effect that will have on the
team who knows but names like that i
think are sort of important to watch
alright let's go through some teams Ian
Rapoport here or NFL Network insider
trade deadline Tuesday 4:00 p.m. Eastern
Time we'll be on live on NFL Network for
all of that the Raiders do you buy Jon
Gruden when he says were pretty much
done
I really don't mainly because you know
he said he said yeah I don't anticipate
any more trades but then he said I
didn't anticipate the last one either
like whoa okay but what does that
actually mean mean timing so you know I
guess they're probably not looking to
make any more trades and I would think
they know the market at this point what
it would probably be but you know you
never know like call Joseph is on the
trade block let's say someone loses
starting safety system fits all of a
sudden they get the trade price they
want then you know they could do a trade
you know Derrick Carter's probably not
getting traded but maybe for servantis
you know I would say the Raiders
certainly could do another trade even if
it would end up surprising Jon Gruden
all right the Giants have traded Damon
Harrison and traded Eli Apple you and I
discussed this on up-to-the-minute on
NFL Network a couple of days ago Eli has
a no trade clause is there a trade that
Eli would agree to and and would they
even consider going down that road I
don't think so
and I don't see why he would you know I
mean look like it's not gonna go to a
contending team and obviously his team
is bad but you know there's something to
be said for finishing your career in the
same place in the reality you only get a
no trade cause if you want to do that
you know what do you waive it to go play
for the Rams like I guess you probably
would but those trades are not happening
you know it would be cause for the to
the Jaguars what you're not going to do
it and where else you know so no I think
similar to last year I think that's kind
of much to do about nothing although
kind of fun to kick around
regardless you mentioned Sam Bradford
what about like Tyrod Taylor or Ryan
Fitzpatrick those veteran quarterbacks
any interest in those guys yeah I mean
you know Tyrod I wondered about with the
Jaguars but do they want to pay a
million dollars for a starter who you
know was not playing well and then got
you know benched after an injury and
they beat last year in the playoffs yeah
I've seen a first-hand look at them not
being good so you know what like that's
a problem you know they've seen Boyles
play good they've invested so much
they're paying him so why would that
make sense
and then Fitzpatrick you know you can
absent at quarterback injury I don't see
where he would end up going I really
don't
right now backing up Jameis Winston by
the way Ryan Griffin is the answer to
whose third on the Buccaneers
quarterback depth charge we were talking
about this yesterday and you said and
I'll just make it easy for you here that
you don't think the bills are gonna
trade LeSean McCoy now he's in
concussion protocol now don't know if he
clears and gets on the field Monday but
he has an extra day they played the
Patriots on on ESPN he's 30
ian like why wouldn't the bills be
actively trying to trade him well you
know the way it's been explained to me
is yes i mean obviously he is thirty
years old but he's looked good he's been
really good in the locker room they
believe he's gonna be on the team next
year and you know we can laugh about
that all you want but we've seen teams
turning around from one year to the next
in football probably more so than any
other sport tending with patrick
peterson you know why would the
cardinals trade patrick peterson and
they're good next year he's gonna help
him part of the solution so they believe
Shady's gonna be on the team next year
and if that's the case then you know
maybe you get a second round or
something you probably trade them I
think they would probably do that thank
you I just don't think that's happening
and many team most teams wouldn't give
up a second-round pick for a thirty year
old running back and I'm not trying to
write a gist here I'm 44 but Frank Gore
is an anomaly what we saw last night
yeah how old do you think I was really
thanks pal yeah I just had a birthday
I'm officially old this is Ian Rapoport
our NFL Network insider want to go back
to to Patrick Peterson because he had a
statement released a statement on
Wednesday
yeah I'm frustrated but I'm here now you
reported last Thursday on the network
you'd spoken to Michael Bidwell he's not
getting traded you were adamant about
that you quoted Bidwell this wasn't like
a you know a deep conversation he had a
quote he's not getting traded basically
not happening did Patrick Peterson have
to issue that did he issue that
statement only because he wanted out and
they told him forget about it and so he
just said I guess I got to put this to
bed because they're not gonna do what
once yeah okay no I mean there was also
conversations where I think they tried
the kind of a suasion you know let him
understand that things were going to be
a little different going forward and you
know some discussion of some improvement
I never definitely conversations I just
think you know it was it was very clear
the whole time he was not getting
trained I know there was interest I know
his cousin was out there tweeting about
things that he wanted to play for he was
never getting traded so the only way to
get in front of it for him was to meet
with the owner and then embrace the
reality which is are you gonna be there
going forward was his desire to leave in
any way a reflection of the mood in the
locker room under new head coach Steve
Wilkes I have not heard that I mean I
know Peterson is frustrated but I have
not heard that about about other players
I mean obviously they're losing so not
like everyone's running around doing
jumping jacks or whatever but I've not
heard specifically anything about the
coach I mean there's you know that that
team's got some issues I mean they got a
lot of first rounders that are not in
the field they got you know they got old
real quick they have a lot of problems
so you know I've not heard specifically
any players say that it's the coaching
chef for sure all right coming up on 34
past the hour this is Ian Rapoport our
NFL Network insider I'm Andrew Siciliano
sitting in for rich who is in London and
is back on Tuesday the voice of Golden
Corral Deion Sanders host this show on
Monday I want to talk about the Browns
real quick tits look we we don't we know
that you had won only one game in two
years and then this year he was I mean
on the hot seat from day number one
obviously here but this past week or two
have been really interesting he they
lose again another heartbreaker and then
Hugh comes out in Tampa Sunday and says
he may take play calling away from Todd
Haley there's a report on Twitter from
the Browns flagship station from their
reporter who covers the team every day
Sunday night that says there's more and
more frustration basically stay tuned
and sites Haslem and Dorsey didn't say
they said but he's hearing
they are more frustrated then Hugh comes
out and says I didn't really mean to say
what I said it was just the heat of the
moment then Todd Haley plays nice
yesterday you and I talked about the
seat getting warmer yesterday on NFL
Network and then they get the Steelers
on Sunday I know that I'm kind of making
a Ward salad here but but could this be
his final game if it goes really badly
Sunday in Pittsburgh I mean I think you
know at this point in the NFL is hard to
rule anything out ever so you know we'll
see how it plays out I think the
frustrations are real the issues are
real you know the fact that the
quarterback had played well at the
beginning and hasn't recently is I think
frustrating to some you know is he gonna
be the coach next year as a team I think
you know it's hard to believe so yeah I
mean if it goes real badly I think we'll
be paying pretty close attention in
Cleveland all right here's here's my
$64,000 question which former head coach
now a coordinator would get the interim
job mmm my guess would be Todd Haley
rather than Craig boy even though Greg
Williams defense is performing far
better than Todd Haley's offense yes why
well you know I think there's Greg
Williams is not for everyone and nope
you know and you kind of look at the
landscape of the franchise which way
it's going brought some new coaches in
hell is one of them my sense is if
something happened they would probably
want to start fresh or rather than you
know give Greg Williams a head coaching
opportunity I would say I'm pretty
strong in that view so I would I would
definitely be surprised if they made a
movement it was Greg Williams taken over
all right real quick
Hugo Cruz who is a down judge he is the
official that was fired yesterday our
news came out yesterday that he was
fired for missing was a blatant Russell
oh [ __ ] false start week six for the
Chargers that led to him that very play
eight IRA will
touchdown pass from Philip Rivers Ian
this is in essence unprecedented that we
fire an official midseason it is
actually unprecedented yeah and you know
it's not for one play I think that was
pretty clear we talked about it on TV
some it was for over the length of his
you know last several games season is
whatever and you know honestly it's good
to see some accountability it's good to
see you don't want to see someone lose
their job but when officials make bad
calls it affects games and people do
lose their jobs because of games so yeah
I mean it didn't the headline was was
you know pretty catchy but it wasn't an
official losing his job because of a bad
call this is clearly a series of bad
calls and but yeah definitely noteworthy
and interesting and who is on your
podcast this week we had Darius Leonard
the Coulomb potential Defensive Rookie
of the Year who's awesome awesome and
cordarrelle Patterson who had two big
touchdowns for the Patriots is he is
including return last week and key day
pretty awesome special teams unit he was
entertaining and obviously I'm on and
I'm always entertaining that important
area so obviously good one okay so Tom
Pella sorrow is the friend on this week
him and Gareth all run every week oh
they're on every week okay yeah okay
I forced them to be on for no pay it's
great and and other do you rotate
friends in we bring on some NFL Network
personalities so as friends different
times Kim has been on a DD duty not you
yet but other people will just leave it
at that
yeah just leave it at that the in
Rappaport and friends podcast and stars
Ian Rapoport you should download it
thanks pal actually you should listen
hello Sarah carofoley and Kim Aditi
whomever they are all friends we're all
friends we
we all work together the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience